all right you impatient thirsty Gremlins
you win you're gonna get my only fans
but it's not here yet all of you hunting
around for the right URL are being
played for a fool because my official
only fans doesn't exist yet I still need
to get my username from the person who
is impersonating me so until you see me
make a video called here where I say the
only Fan's link is in the description
below you know it's not official yet and
you will have to wait a little bit
longer because like I said in my live
stream the other day they didn't go out
to absolutely everybody I didn't exactly
have my tasteful nudes ready to go I
didn't think you'd get there that fast
but you're not there yet I still have to
work on my mom's documentary you didn't
forget about that did you that was one
of my conditions because I imagine that
if you got your hands on my only fans
you'd be so busy that you would forget
to show up at the right time so I'm
saving you from yourself I watch
everything you wouldn't disappoint my
mom like that
like how I'm disappointing my mom with
this only fans you wouldn't do that
would you
I'm helping you so just be patient until
the deal is complete and then as
promised at the end of this month you
will have the only fan stock to the brim
with
the most tasteful of nudes but don't
expect anything that wasn't in my
calendar before like that should be
obvious if you have my calendar you know
what to expect if you didn't get my
calendar you just wait you'll see
okay everybody understand cool and in
other news uh I found out yesterday that
in space with markiplier was nominated
for an Emmy
like a real Emmy
which is big news that's really cool so
thank you uh everyone who watched the
show and supported it it was a big
effort from a lot of people and it means
a lot
so thank you
be there for my mom's documentary